good morning john i'm not sure if you
know about days since hankgreen started
a new thing.com
it's a joke among some people on twitter
who have noticed that the amount of time
between when i start a new thing
and when i start another new thing is
often not a long period of time canada
currently stands at seven days since we
launched the life's little eyes tik tok
now this is a funny thing but it's also
something that i'm simultaneously like
proud of
and terrified of like what exactly is
wrong with me and the website actually
has a tiny little link at the bottom
that shows you all of the things i've
done terrifying but an impressively long
list
on the other hand it's riddled with
failure in 2020 for example there are 11
listed projects only four of them
are still like existing things though
three of them were jokes like my only
fans for pelican
pictures anyway because i have this
habit people often ask me about like
how do you get ideas how do you start
things and i can't tell you how to have
an idea but i can tell you what an idea
is which is a thing that i think a lot
of people get wrong so let's walk
through the three main stages of
intentional creation
the thought the idea and the thing
thoughts are not ideas here's an example
of some thoughts
gosh we sure do need to raise a lot of
money for a maternal center of
excellence in sierra leone creators at
dftba.com seem to be having a lot of
success with socks lately wow i am
amazed by the number and quality of
independent artists out there those are
not things that have anything to do with
each other but more importantly
they're not going anywhere they're not
pointing in a direction i find it useful
to have a list of thoughts that might go
somewhere i don't know where they're
going and no you can't see it it is a
silly place
ideas are when you combine some thoughts
together and at the end of the
combination
you have an objective you would like to
accomplish
and a way to get there some kind of path
for our example an idea might be
what if there was a sock subscription
where every month you got a sock from a
different independent artist and 100 of
the profit went to charity there's a
goal there and there's a bunch of
thoughts that we think are true that are
going to help us get to that goal we
have combined our thoughts together to
have an objective and a way to get to it
and then there's the part where you make
the idea
a thing the implementation the work the
awesome socks club has now donated over
200 000
to the maternal center of excellence in
sierra leone but getting it to this
point and continuing to keep it alive
is a whole thing like there's a lot of
people involved i just happen to know a
person here in missoula montana who's in
the sock business
like i don't know if we could have done
it without her and of course in the act
of implementation your idea changes like
we originally thought that our artists
were going to be one of our main
marketing vehicles but then we realized
that we didn't want
to share all of the socks we wanted most
of them to be surprises
and it would be weird for artists to be
marketing a thing that they couldn't
show to people so we changed our
marketing strategy to include
a bunch of tick-tock people who i had
met recently and now it's its own
existing thing but it's still an idea
but also and this is often the case and
how businesses
happen it started to spin off new ideas
like we have this thing now and it's
working so what else can we do with that
which is why
i've never done this before i am looking
for a product lead
and co-founder for a new business that i
want to start there's an application for
that job in the description
let people who you think are cool and
interesting and might want to work on
something
exceptionally weird know about it john
i'll see you on tuesday